[Musique]
bienvenue dans le duel des éditos votre
émission politique hebdomadaire
pour cette dernière émission de 2021
alexis poulin et jacques de guillebon
reviennent sur le meilleur et le pire de
l'année politique prince culte les
sondages ça va et vient c'est comme la
queue du chien ou comme ratée ami tu
sais le best-of des éditos nos
éditorialistes livreront ensuite leurs
scénarios les plus fous pour cette
présidentielle de 2022 ils reviendront
ensuite enfants des missions sur une
actu qui mérite éclairage dans le monde
d'après mais d'abord retour sur
l'interview d'emmanuel macron hier soir
tf1 a diffusé en prime time un entretien
avec le président tourné il ya plusieurs
jours s'il n'a pas annoncé sa
candidature le président de la
république en a tout de même profité
pour brosser le bilan de son quinquennat
alors messieurs une question simple pour
ouvrir le débat est ce que comme valérie
pécresse vous pensez que cette
intervention porte atteinte à l'équité
entre les candidats
bonjour alexis jacques mais non
évidemment cette interview a été
parfaitement logique et loyal comme
chacun sait le grand roi macron avait le
droit d'exposer son bilan de cette année
et se brosser plutôt lui-même dans le
sens du poil plutôt que de grossesse on
son bilan c'était évidemment il manquait
que stéphane bern en fait c'était un peu
un documentaire à la gloire des manuels
macron dont il était le héros et le
prévoir il est le producteur facettes
été fameux producteur mais grossière
mise en scène avec les gros plans sur
les moments émotions et puis ben evans
et le maquereau qui dit aux français
qu'il est le meilleur président que les
français aient jamais connues alors il a
commis quelques petites erreurs il a eu
peut-être quelques faiblesses mais quand
même il est génial à deux heures pour ça
évidemment c'est inquiétant de voir un
pays comme la france en arrive là avec
cette mise en scène de propagande dans
le palais de l'élysée darrois quasiment
à cette façon de dire qu'il ya une
parole autorisé puis une parole qui est
quasiment interdite ou dévaloriser celle
des citoyens et puis à miroir miroir mon
beau miroir qui est finalement assez
inutile je pense que allah au final à
part les supporters les fans emmanuel
macron il ya une fatigue je pense de ce
personnage et le fait aussi qu'il
devient de moins en moins audibles ou
qu'ils montrent une certaine fébrilité
par rapport à la campagne qui approche
vous êtes bien optimiste moi je pense
plutôt que ça marchait comme d'habitude
que ce qu'il a des faiblesses sont les
rock et des faiblesses sinon il serait
encore moins à l'envoi de certains c'est
une sorte d'intelligence artificielle
qui voudraient se rendre aimable
voudrait qu'on aime c'est notre raïssa
nous et il sera notre ami donc ses
faiblesses qu'il en joue même et c'est
enfin on a vu son talent de comédien de
son seul talent de comédien d'ailleurs
avec ses gros plans sur les moments où
d'émotion où il se souvenait de ces
choses affreuses qu'il avait vu qu'ils
ont touchées et oui il a apris voilà où
il a des qualités évidemment on a vu
nicolas sarkozy avec son j'ai changé lui
c'était j'ai appris voilà je serai
encore un meilleur président que j'ai
été si c'était possible il ya plusieurs
messages qui font froid dans le dos en
réalité derrière l'exercice de
communication pour montrer à maquereau
humain il a dit je suis humain je suis
dans l'affectif de très humain très
humain très humain oui ça on l'a vu on
l'a vu lors des manifestations des gilet
jaune mais ce qui m'a le plus fait peur
c'est surtout le fait qu'ils ne disent
pas à demi mot qu'il est là pour
installer une société de la vigilance
quand la journaliste lui pose la
question d'une société de surveillance
il dit simplement que pour lui c'est une
société de vigilance c'est la même chose
ça veut dire que c'est une société où
les libertés deviennent finalement
l'exception plutôt que la règle et plus
ça va aller et moins nous aurons de
liberté je suis et vous le savez en
train de dénoncer le pass annie terre
depuis le début de la mise en place de
cette liste de ce dispositif clairement
on voit que la feuille de route va aller
plus loin techno surveillance
biosurveillance le drone la cnil a beau
alerté on a vu la faillite du conseil
d'état du conseil constitutionnel nos
libertés sont en danger avec le
programme le projet d' emmanuel macron
enfin je suis pas d'accord avec vous là
dessus mais moi je pense que ce n'est
pas la pire chose qu'il ait faite mais
ce qui l'est moins ce qu'il m'envoie
serait plus chez lui c'est vraiment non
seulement il est auto centrée non plus
on a l'impression qu'il est seul c'est
vraiment le roi soleil qui illumine tout
le monde et qui attire tout à lui fin et
il n'a évoqué aucun de ses adversaires
directement et surtout aucun de ses
alliés aucun de ses ministres le premier
ministre c'est ça qui n'existera plus
premier ministre et en bulles ministre
on se mit à même pas son parti à me
passer des ventes et il est seul et il
alla il à la vraie parole et il a
soutenu d'ailleurs sont en même temps se
vantant de son en même temps en disant
c'est parce qu'il est juste et efficace
voilà donc lui c'est ce qui est juste et
ce qui est efficace et il n'y a aucune
discussion là dessus et quoiqu'il se
passe il a toujours raison il a une
réponse à tout oui alors ce qui est
assez terrible c'est si ça fonctionne
parce qu'en réalité le bilan des deux
manuels macron et pas forcément
défendable ou difficilement défendable
l'inflation explose il pouvoir d'achat
il a beau se défendre et faire croire
qu'ils augmentaient pour de nombreux
français ce n'est pas le cas la réforme
de la retraite qu'il devait faire lui le
grand réformateur il n'a pas pu la faire
et pour le reste demandez à n'importe
quel français dans la rue caf emmanuelle
coint macron pour vous ces cinq
dernières années
il se sera bien difficile d'avoir une
réponse claire et cohérente en réalité
on a là une boursouflure de narcissique
de quelqu'un qui défend un bilan
indéfendable en disant qu'il est le
meilleur et ça fonctionne avec des
mouvements de caméra tout simplement en
essayant de jouer de ce que vous disiez
ce mauvais jeu d'acteur de quelqu'un qui
incarne une fonction qui n'est pas fait
pour lui avec en plus ce petit côté
histrionnais en dix ans les français le
peuple français a fait confiance à un
jeune homme de 39 ans non ils n'ont pas
fait confiance ils ont voté parce qu'à
l'époque il y avait un second tour
emmanuel macron marine le pen et lui a
volé ce vote finalement pour faire
croire qu'il avait derrière ce vote un
blanc seing pour dérouler un projet qui
n'est pas celui des français d'ailleurs
on le voit aujourd'hui avec cette
campagne présidentielle qui commence et
les nombreux candidats qui sont contre
le projet d' emmanuel macron oui surtout
on voit qu'il a parlé d'un peu près rien
sinon banquiers macro qui est ressorti
c'est à dire que c'est sa théorie du
ruissellement regardez j'ai fait revenir
des grandes fortunes en france donc on
va ré industrialiser donc ça va bien se
passer et on va tous devenir riche
évidemment fins et guizot cent cinquante
ans après 200 ans après il a joué parlé
d'écologie il a jamais parlé eux mêmes
d'immigration d'insécurité très peu pas
de politique internationale pas d'europe
fait c'est simplement un satisfecit sur
voilà vous avez l'impression de vivre
mieux vaut avoir un peu plus d'argent et
donc réaliser moi là dessus mais c'est
par un chef d'état là dessus c'est
certain c'est un petit garçon voilà très
boursouflé très narcissique qui
qui est beau qui plaît et qui va emmener
la france vers des jours meilleurs mais
qui sont simplement des jours de on va
gagner plus voilà il n'y a pas de vision
du tout on ne sait pas quelle est sa
perspective ans n'est pas calé vision de
la france qu'elle et son amour de la
france même s'ils le répète mille fois à
part ça y'a pas grand chose non c'est
vrai qu'au delà de cet exercice
narcissique de la mise en scène de la
personne macron qui essaye de se
chercher d'une personnalité aucun projet
pour le pays aucune notion finalement de
ce qu'est la france il esquisse la
laïcité quelques quelques comme ça et
sujet mais la réalité profonde c'est que
c'est un communicant et ça cette
séquence là c'était je veux montrer que
je suis en pâtit que je suis humain et
c'était tout et comme la séquence de la
semaine précédente était je veux montrer
que je suis un super président pour le
conseil de l'europe et et la prochaine
séquence ce sera je veux montrer que je
suis un super père noël je ne suis pas
en tout cas voilà il se déguise depuis
cinq ans et il continue de le faire
c'était le cas de l'exercice d'hier
place au débat de la semaine que nous
réserve cette campagne présidentielle
fin 2016 à la même période les français
étaient loin de s'imaginer ce que leur
réserverez l'élection de 2017
françois fillon était le mieux placé
dans les sondages
emmanuel macron n'était que troisième et
on imaginait encore que manuel valls
pourrait remporter la primaire de la
gauche alors 2022 va t'elle réservé son
lot de surprises et des alliances
inattendues des retraits de certains
candidats mais avant de s'intéresser à
l'année prochaine revenons sur 2021
messieurs selon vous quels ont été les
trois faits politiques les plus
marquants de l'année écoulée
[Musique]
et
bien pour moi les trois faits les plus
marquants de 2021 c'est d'abord la
candidature d'eric zemmour surprenante
qui a mis un peu de piment sur cette
élection présidentielle ensuite l'échec
d'al hidalgo on aurait pu croire qu'elle
aurait fait quelque chose du parti
socialiste que quelque chose se serait
passé à gauche cette gauche là et là on
voit que ça ne fonctionne pas du tout et
puis ce qu vide 19 21 22 à coville qui
n'en finit pas des vagues dont on ne
compte plus le nombre voilà pour moi les
faits marquants de cette année
moi j'aurais le même fait marquant le
même premier fait marquant qui est aussi
la candidature d'eric zemmour et son
ascension jusqu'à son tassement
maintenant mais qu'elles me en tout cas
troubler le jeu à l'extrême droite est à
droite le deuxième c'est un autre
trouble à l'intérieur de la droite dans
ce cas la plus classique qui est
l'élection valérie pécresse qui était
assez peu attendu et ce parti qui se
dote d'une femme qui est en plus elle
même montée jusqu'à 20% une fois qu'elle
est devenu le chef de ce parti très
légitimiste et le troisième c'est encore
une femme qui n'a pas gagné hélas ou
tant mieux c'est sandrine rousseau qui
est venue elle troubler le jeu à gauche
et du côté des écologistes avec son son
discours très descriptif notamment sur
les femmes les racisées locaux qui se
moque ouais on voit que dans nos choix
c'est surtout la surprise un effet de
surprise qui compte dans ses best of de
2021 mais ce qu'on attend avant de faire
de la prospective c'est d'essayer de
comprendre en fait cette annexe
qu'est-ce qui pourrait bousculer les
lignes parce que ce centre cette maison
commune qui essaye d'être construit sur
les cendres et les ruines de la
république en marche c'est continuer
cette politique finalement
technocratique européiste d' emmanuel
macron de dire je continue cette feuille
de route très simple on vendait à la
découpe on continue privatiser on enlève
les lois sociales le petit à petit et
les français travailleront jusqu'à 65 67
ans et là arrive dans nos différents
choix le fait de dire que quelque chose
pourrait changer à la fois le co vide
qui a changé l'agenda des réformes la
candidature d'eric zemmour qui pousse
aussi tous les candidats à se
positionner par rapport à des sujets
tabous il immigration la question aussi
de la nation la question d'identité
qu'on ne voulait pas revoir mis sur la
table et qui pourtant arrive même dans
le discours des vins de mâcon sur
l'europe d'ailleurs il parle d'identité
européenne
et puis évidemment la restructuration
des partis parce que cette centrifugeuse
du centre a poussé tout le monde deux
extrêmes mais est ce que un pôle de
gauche et un pôle de droite peuvent se
reformer être fort et refaire une
politique qui a du sens une politique d
idées pas moi ce qui m'angoisse et
surtout l'irruption à gauche d'une
candidate works on peut dire enfin
candidate à la candidature pour la
première fois qui a été son âne rousseau
qui est un discours que moi je trouve
parfaitement absurde et parfaitement
inquiété en r j'aimerais bien qu'on
écoute de seconde pour en parler
aujourd'hui tout notre système
économique
tout notre système social tout notre
système sociétal est fondé sur ce
triptyque nous prenons nous utilisons et
nous jetons nous prenons nous utilisons
et nous jetons le corps des femmes nous
prenons nous utilisons et nous jetons le
corps des plus précaires dans la société
nous prenons nous utilisons et nous
jetons le corps d racisées nous ne
voulons plus de ce système là et c'est
ça la révolution que je vous propose
voilà sa révolution et un peu
inquiétante c'est à dire que là on a un
exemple d'un terreau sectional it est
parfaite on prend on utilise on jette
c'est censé être définition écologique
du monde enfin c'est à dire ce concours
une écologie voudrais vous devrez lutter
ll le transfert sur le corps de toutes
les victimes supposées de la société qui
sont là en l'occurrence les femmes les
racisées pourrait rajouter les
handicapés tout ce qu'on veut offrir
voilà et ce discours qui se formulent à
gauche qui est en train de se
concrétiser et peut-être de se délecter
de prendre forme même s'il a échoué à
mon avis pour l'instant dans cette dans
cette campagne là quelque chose qui -
maquette pour les années à venir est
quelque chose qui voilà qui pourrait
arriver et venir
mr former une gauche autour de ces
concepts les plus radicaux ses
concepteurs a dit qu ils sont finalement
pas nouveaux ils sont juste englober est
pris dans le débat français sandrine
rousseau moi j'ai trouvé qu'elle a été
extrêmement stratège en disant là il ya
une case que personne n'a pris je vais
pousser le curseur encore plus loin dans
cette radicalité là pour voir jusqu'où
je peux aller et c'est un succès elle
n'existait pas sur la scène politique
aujourd'hui elles mêmes à cailloux dans
la chaussure de yannick jadot pour sa
candidature elle pourrait rejoindre la
campagne de jean-luc un jeu on ne sait
plus et elle compte elle compte dans le
débat c'est ça qui est assez incroyable
avec ce discours radical mais je pense
que le discours radical c'est le même de
l'autre côté de celui d'eric zemmour qui
a gagné aussi beaucoup de temps
d'antenne 2 voies avec un discours
radical donc l'idée d'être radical pour
être entendus malheureusement c'est
devenu le fait du débat aujourd'hui
politique oui bon je trouve ça pouvait
être lu de m en vis à vis et de
radicalité fier de dire que c'est la
même chose sachant qu à mon avis eric
zemmour et où marine le pen essaye de
répondre à des peurs qui existe depuis
trente ou quarante ans dans la société
française et qu'on met sous le tapis qui
explique le fait qu'ils y monte puisque
personne pour l'instant il ya répondu
shdm et puisqu'on est on vient de faire
ce bilan pour nous de 1021 je pense
qu'ils aient un peu de prospective dans
ce temps de noël du tournant de l'année
serait assez amusant allons essayer
d'imaginer des scénarios un peu fou pour
2022 moi c'est à dire ce serait pas mon
rêve le plus fou mais mon cauchemar de
plus fous on peut dire ce serait
d'imaginer que justement dans la lignée
de cette sandrine rousseau qui a été
écarté pour l'instant christiane taubira
qui est en train d'être poussés par une
primaire populaire comme on me dit de
200000 personnes qui veulent élire en
dehors des partis leur candidat le plus
à même de représenter toute la gauche
christiane taubira donc deviennent cette
candidate quasi unique de la gauche
rassemble sous son nom et soit capable
de passer au second tour
imaginons voilà que la gauche se
réveillent que les français se mettent à
avoir peur de la fin du monde donc de
l'écologie mais pas uniquement
de la fin du mois mais aussi la fin du
mois en regardant combien macro à mener
une politique libérale et comment ils en
train de détruire la france sur ce plan
là cette gauche se réveillent
plein de volonté de justice sociale
pleine de volonté d'un terreau sectional
it et voyant christiane taubira une
grande poétesse et une grande politique
capable et à même de réduire toutes les
inégalités et donc se retrouver au
second tour face à emmanuel macron
qu'elle bat à plates coutures et voilà
et on se retrouve avec christiane
taubira comme président de la république
en avril prochain voilà mon scénario fou
fou on en parlera de christiane taubira
dans le monde d'après alors moi mon
scénario fou et j'ai peut-être pas aussi
fou que le vôtre moi j'imagine à macron
empêcher un maquereau qui ne peut pas se
présenter soit par un scandale sorti du
coffre d'alexandre benallal affaires de
l'été n'ont pas la sphère d'étape ou
bien un choix personnel des difficultés
avec la crise du cornât virus ou autres
et un deuxième tour étonnant où on
trouverait
eric zemmour face à jean luc mélenchon
mélenchon qui serait finalement le seul
à gauche capable de faire une union et
tout le monde se rassemblera dix ans
vont finalement on n'a plus que quatre
mois allons-y nous n'avons pas le choix
eric zemmour qui frère à hold up de la
droite avec valérie pécresse qui
descendraient dans les sondages et
aurait du mal à imprimer parce que elle
ferait finalement la suite de mâcon
alors c'est complètement fou hein vous
allez me dire et dans ce deuxième tour
je verrai pourquoi pas la victoire
d'eric zemmour qui lui du coup réussi
réart fédérer la droite alors que jean
luc mélenchon bien la gauche étant
tellement divisée se ferait évidemment
descendre par ses alliés je sens que
j'ai très envie de radicalité de manière
intentionnelle et voilà on passe après
elles sont en train de se battre et de
faire exploser le système quick alors
plus classiquement après ces scénarios
rêver ou cauchemarder chez quand elle
l'un et l'autre ce qui semble se
profiler et ça n'est pas besoin d'être
mon avis grand clerc pour le savoir
c'est que c'est en train de se
rassembler sur un libéralisme
aujourd'hui cette élection de
centre-droit et de centre-gauche qui
sont incarnés par valérie pécresse et
emmanuel macron et que hélas moi je
pense le lait français encore une fois
sont plus fins et là ce sont plus
soucieux de leur fin de mois que la fin
du monde ou que de la fin de la france
dire que les deux grands thèmes que sont
l'immigration l'assimilation la sécurité
sont des thèmes que les français
ressentent péniblement une raison en est
qu'il soit résolu mais il ya des thèmes
qui sont plus importants pour leur loi
dans tous les sondages c'est leur santé
leur retraite leurs revenus et leur fin
du mois et là-dessus les deux qui ont le
discours le plus apparemment raisonnable
comme depuis 40 ans et valérie pécresse
emmanuel macron je pense que si pécresse
se décrit comme un tiers merkel et deux
tiers thatcher ou l' inverse je sais
plus ce n'est pas anodin et on voit que
ce sont les mêmes c'est à dire tous les
ministres de d'emmanuel macron une
grande partie viennent du camp des
républicains et donc leurs théories
libérales sont à peu près les mêmes vont
essayer de créer un cercle de la raison
en disant regardez nous c'est nous qui
savons baisser les impôts baisser les
cotisations sociales relancer le
l'économie et assurer vos retraites
voilà ce qui est très important en
france vu le nombre d'électeurs
plutôt âgées qui font une grande part de
l'électorat et donc je pense que et là
c'est d'après moi ça va se resserrer
autour de ces deux personnages là et que
voilà le la victoire je ne sais pas et
il ira mais ce sera un de ces deux là
j'ai exactement le même scénario
macron pécresse au second tour parce
qu'évidemment ce sont les deux pôles
un qui est le pôle médiatique qui est le
président sortant il n'a pas ce parti
qui est un parti intégrés dans les
territoires c'est le cas de l air qui
l'a peut faire campagne à labourer la
campagne est justement trouver du monde
des signatures mais aussi des militants
et mais qui vont finalement
avoir quelques arguties sur des sujets
qui seront les même prolonger la durée
du temps de travail
8 et les droits sociaux quel est le
poids de la fonction publique dans le
budget de l'étape bref on va retrouver
les mêmes et puis aucune question sur
l'intégration européenne et la feuille
de route de bruxelles donc là on aura à
peu près la même chose la question c'est
est ce que cette élection va se
transformer en un référendum pour ou
contre 50 plus de macron est ce que les
français veulent 50 plus des manuels
macron ça c'est la vraie question donc
si valérie pécresse se trouve face
emmanuel macron elle serait en position
évidemment de pouvoir potentiellement
dégager et se serait même dans l'intérêt
de partis de gauche comme le parti
socialiste qui pourrait se refaire parce
que justement la république en marche
cette bulle de cinq ans ce disparaîtrait
exploserait directement je ne pense pas
qu emmanuel macron s'il n'est pas élu
pourrait placer des candidats même avec
la maison commune où horizons ce serait
extrêmement difficile d'avoir des
députés de la république en marche qui
est un nouveau mandat donc là on
retrouverait une pole classique de
gauche et droite à l'assemblée nationale
est peut-être un régime un peu plus
parlementaire donc voilà peut-être une
chance pour valérie pécresse si elle est
au second tour oui mais encore
faudrait-il que les rites et crêtes
fasse la preuve qu'elle peut être une
femme d'état c'est un chouette je pense
que là où emmanuel macron a compris
quand même quelque chose de profond de
la société française c'est ce reste
monarchique on peut dire que le général
de gaulle avait bien compris sur la vème
république donc c'est à dire de de
volonté d'un homme fort quand même fort
je dis pas que c'est un dictateur ou un
tyran mais en tout cas quelqu'un qui se
place au dessus et à part la parenthèse
hollande si on peut dire c'est toujours
été un peu le cas dans les présidents
que sont allés se chercher des français
regardez un françois mitterrand a été
réélu en 88 alors que son bilan était
quand même plutôt désastreux même s'il
avait bénéficié de d'une cohabitation
avec chirac mais
les gens aimés mitterrand l'ont réélue
en 88 parce qu'il avait donné cette
sensation d'être un homme au-dessus du
but il est plus intelligent une sorte de
liu vice pater enfin de jupiter
exactement ces comprimés la rédaction et
pour l'instant c'est ce que macron a
essayé de faire et qu'on a vu hier et
valérie pécresse aura beaucoup de
travail et mon avis pour essayer de se
hisser à ce niveau là bas de toute façon
elle est les candidates elle n'est pas
président de sortante elle est
présidente de région et puis elle prend
aussi une voix délicate parce que si
pour elle le sérieux c'est de dire que
le pass and iter doit être prolongée
après juillet que la vaccination va être
obligatoire qu'il faudra travailler
encore plus longtemps enfin elle ne
promet que du sang et des larmes d'une
certaine façon ce n'est pas quelque
chose non plus qui donne envie et puis
il ya cette question de la ligne quelle
peut être la ligne pécresse si pour le
moment au rex yacht y reste dans les
rangs ça peut très bien bouger si jamais
elle devient trop macro nist ou bien
trop centriste il ya quand même chez l
air cette fracture qui reste même si
elle est cachée pour le moment pendant
la campagne et qui pourraient surprendre
si elle ne tient pas ses troupes oui et
je pense que la vraie fracture chez
averses et surtout générationnel c'est à
dire que l air fait un carton chez les
plus de 70 ans tout le reste en dessous
ils sont à des scores minables
contrairement emmanuel macron qui a ce
talent de prendre dans chacune des
catégories de manière à peu près égale
donc moi je serais plutôt pour l'instant
pour un maquereau pour cinq ans
direction le monde d'après alexis poule
a et jacques de guillebon vous apportent
leur éclairage chaque semaine sur une
information qui pourrait faire
l'actualité politique de demain
commençons par vous jacques selon vous
quelles infos mérite cette semaine un
coup de projecteur
[Musique]
l'info de cette semaine pour moi c'est
pour en revenir à valérie pécresse c'est
la présence derrière elle ce n'est pas
nouveau mais en tout cas il se dévoile
de plus en plus de patrick stefanini qui
est donc son directeur de campagne qui
est assez peu connu du grand public même
s'ils commencent à l'être un peu plus ce
qui a mené la campagne de chirac en 95
caramel et encore d'autres entre-temps
qui a fait élire valérie pécresse
présidente de région à la fois en 2015
et en 2020 enfin je ne sommes que des
dates exactes enfin bref aux deux
dernières régionales qui a été directeur
de campagne de françois fillon avec cet
échec que l'on sait mais qui n'est pas
du tout dû à la stratégie de patrick
stefanini qui est un homme qui en plus a
publié un livre sur l'immigration très
remarqué il ya un an qui va marcher sur
les plates-bandes de marine le pen et
d'eric zemmour voilà c'est un livre qui
tient plutôt la sonnette d alarme sur
l'immigration dont il est capable de
rassurer cette frange la dlr qui aurait
tendance à partir plus adroits nizon
parce que déçu de l'absence de réaction
des républicains dans ces dernières
années sur la question de l'immigration
et de l'insécurité et qui est voilà un
vrai stratège quelqu'un qui est local
fois un énarque après fait donc un grand
organisateur est aussi quelqu'un qui a
une qui a une vision politique et qui à
mon avis est un atout maître dans la
manche de valérie pécresse et qui
pourrait l'amener très très haut si ça
continue comme ça quelqu'un de cap et
qui sait ce qu'il fait dans la campagne
pour moi le le fait de la semaine et le
monde d'après c'est évidemment la
primaire populaire à gauche on s'agite
dans tous les sens et arnaud montebourg
qui passe des coups de fil à tout le
monde il faut faire l'union anne hidalgo
qui propose cette primaire en disant si
j'y vais allons-y et puis derrière cette
primaire populaire en fait une sorte
d'appareil créé dès le début pour
préparer la candidature de christiane
taubira qui n'y va pas on ne sait jamais
si elle y va si elle n'y va pas
il ya un vrai problème de fond c'est que
on parle de personnalités on parle
finalement de coups de com jamais de
programmer jamais de qu'est ce qui fait
que les électeurs de gauche sont aussi
éclatés et ne trouve pas un champion
parce que la gauche elle est complexé
contrairement à la droite qui s'est
décomplexé on a un parti socialiste qui
est dans le camp des perdants clairement
aujourd'hui la plupart des gens parti
socialiste font le deuil de la
présidentielle de 2000 22 ans dix ans on
fera en sorte d'essayer de placer
quelques députés en s'arrangeant avec
les uns et les autres mais on ne cherche
même plus à faire campagne et je crois
que cette primaire populaire c'est une
sorte de
deux bottage en touche de dire
simplement ben voilà on va essayer de
faire croire qu'on continue la campagne
à quatre mois du scrutin ça me paraît
totalement illusoire de sortir de la
manche christiane taubira malgré les
sondages qui dirait que oui les
électeurs de gauche souhaite l'union et
autour de christiane taubira je pense
que c'est encore un effet totalement
illusoire et qui n'aura pas vraiment
d'impact sur le sur le camp de gauche
oui je pense que la gauche les victimes
du régime des partis c'est à dire que là
on voit que des boutiques qui cherche à
se perpétuer le cas du parti socialiste
c'est le cas aussi je pense de mélenchon
7 qui a du parti communiste c'est
uniquement pour pouvoir continuer à
avoir des élus des députés ensuite et
c'est le parti devient le but ultime et
non plus que c'est ça l'instrument est
l'outil tel qu'il devrait être donc je
pense que la gauche qui est déjà assez
basses toutes réunies qui est fait à
peine un peu plus de 25% ce qui est
quand même assez bas et pitoyable pour
ce ce mouvement d'idées et en plus
segmenté en quatre ou cinq personnes et
il ya que vous vous l'avais dit il ya
très peu de chances que christiane
taubira arrive à cela se passait au
dessus sachant que les stones taubira
malgré ses qualités de femme politique
d'oratrice reste quand même celle qui a
fait perdre lionel jospin en 2002 mais
ça je sais pas si je pense que tout le
monde ne l'a pas oublié et qui avait
conduit donc je marie le pen au second
tour donc il reste quand même cette
tâche sur sur sa candidature qui avait
fait campagne aussi pour edouard
balladur enfin bon voilà c'est quelqu'un
quand même qui a un profil du en même
temps assez classique et puis qui a
accompagné le quinquennat de hollande en
fait la gauche doit faire à la fois le
bilan et le deuil du parti socialiste si
elle veut de nouveau exister et
aujourd'hui le parti socialiste ne veut
pas mourir de sa belle mort donc on
arrive avec ces empêchements perpétuelle
ces personnalités qui voudraient revenir
d'ailleurs il y avait un kiki qui
critiquaient cette absence de débat se
tester fans le foll au parti socialiste
en dix ans c'est pas c'est pas ça un
parti c'est plus ça c'est vrai qu'on en
est très très loin voilà on finit
l'année avec ce bilan et ses projections
merci jacques djoli noël les jeux et
noël et à bientôt bientôt
c'est la fin du duel des éditos vous
pouvez retrouver cette émission en
replay sur notre site rt france point tv
et en podcast sur toutes les plateformes
vous pouvez également réagir dans les
commentaires et sur les réseaux sociaux
via le hashtag ldd eux à la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau duel des
éditos
[Musique]